In the Quran, Allah brags about being
the best at all kinds of things. He's
the best of helpers, the best of
sustainers, the best of judges, the best
of forgivers, the best of plotters,
planners, schemers, deceivers, however
you want to translate it. He's the best
of inheritors, the best of creators, the
best of providers, and so on. But of all
the things Allah does in the Quran,
there's one thing he does better than
anything else. Allah is the best of
Bible confirmers. He's the best at
confirming the inspiration,
preservation, and authority of the
Bible. Now, there are dozens of Quran
verses that confirm the Jewish and
Christian scriptures, but in this video,
we're just going to look at Quran verses
that actually use the word confirm.
Again, the Quran confirms the Bible in
many other ways, but for now, we're only
going to read Quran verses that
specifically say confirm. And we better
get started because there are a lot of
them. Surah 2 verse 41. Allah is
speaking to the Jews and he says, "And
believe in that which I have sent down,
the Quran, confirming that which you
have with you and be not the first to
disbelieve in it and sell not my signs
for a poultry price and reverence me."
Notice Allah tells the Jews that they
should believe in the Quran because the
Quran confirms what they have with them.
Surah 2 verse 89. And when there came to
them a book from God, the Quran,
confirming that which they had with
them, and a four time they used to ask
for victory over those who disbelieve,
so when there came to them that which
they recognized, they disbelieved in it.
So may the curse of God be upon the
disbelievers. The Quran confirmed what
they had with them. Surahu verse 91. And
when it is said unto them, believe in
what God has sent down in the Quran,
they say, "We believe in what was sent
down to us." And they disbelieve in what
is beyond it, although it is the truth
confirming what is with them. Say, "Then
why did you slay the prophets of God a
four time if you were believers?" What
does the Quran do? It confirms what is
with them. Surah 2 verse 97. Whosoever
is an enemy of Gabriel, he it is who
sent down upon thy heart, Muhammad's
heart, by God's leave, confirming that
which was there before, and as a
guidance and glad tiding for the
believers. Muhammad's revelations
confirm what was there before. Surah 2
verse 101. And when there came to them a
messenger from God, Muhammad, confirming
that which is with them, a group of
those who have been given the book cast
the book of God behind their backs as if
they know not. Muhammad confirmed what
was already with them, but they
pretended they didn't know it. Surah
3:es 3:4 He Allah sent down the book the
Quran upon thee Muhammad in truth
confirming what was before it and he
sent down the Torah and the Gospel of
four time as a guidance to mankind and
he sent down the criterion truly those
who disbelieve in the signs of God shall
have a severe punishment and God is
mighty possessor of vengeance
The Quran confirms what was before it.
And Allah specifically mentions the
Torah and the Gospel. Surah 3:50, this
is Jesus speaking. Jesus says, "And I
come confirming that which was before
me, the Torah, and to make lawful unto
you part of that which was forbidden
unto you. And I have come to you with a
sign from your Lord. So reverence God
and obey me." Jesus confirmed the Torah.
Surah
3:81. And remember, when God made the
covenant of the prophets, by that which
I have given you of a book and wisdom,
should a messenger then come to you
confirming that which is with you, you
shall surely believe in him, and you
shall help him. He said, "Do you agree
and take on my burden on these
conditions?" They said, "We agree." He
said, "Bear witness, for I am with you
among those who bear witness." God made
a covenant with the prophets and thereby
with their followers that if a messenger
were to come to them confirming what was
with them, they would have to believe in
him. That's why they were supposed to
believe in Muhammad when he came to them
confirming what was with them. Surah
4:47. Oh you unto whom the book has been
given, believe in what we have sent
down, the Quran, confirming that which
is with you before we blot out faces and
turn them backwards or curse them as we
cursed those who broke the Sabbath. And
the command of God shall be fulfilled.
Here Allah is speaking to the people of
the book and he tells them to believe in
the Quran which confirms what was with
them. Surah
5:46 and in their footsteps we sent
Jesus son of Mary confirming the Torah
that had come before him and we gave him
the gospel wherein is a guidance and a
light confirming the Torah that had come
before him as a guidance and an
exhortation to the reverend. Here we
have a double confirmation. Jesus
confirms the Torah that came before him
and the gospel confirms the Torah that
came before him. Surah
5:48. And we have sent down unto thee,
Muhammad, the book, the Quran, in truth,
confirming the book that came before it,
and as a protector over it. So judge
between them in accordance with what God
has sent down, and follow not their
caprices away from the truth that has
come unto thee. For each among you, we
have appointed a law and a way. And had
God w, he would have made you one
community. But he willed otherwise, that
he might try you in that which he has
given you. So vi with one another in
good deeds. Unto God shall be your
return altogether, and he will inform
you of that wherein you differ. The
Quran confirms the book of the people of
the book and the Quran is a protector
over this book. Weird that our Muslim
friends attack the Bible when Allah says
the Quran protects it. Surah
6:92. And this the Quran is a blessed
book that we have sent down confirming
that which came before it that thou
mayest warn the mother of cities and
those around her. Those who believe in
the hereafter believe in it and they are
mindful of their prayers. The Quran
confirms what came before it. Surah 10
verse 37. This Quran could not have been
fabricated by anyone apart from God.
Rather it is a confirmation of that
which came before it and an elaboration
of the book in which there is no doubt
from the Lord of the worlds. The Quran
confirms and
elaborates surah 12 verse 111. Certainly
in their stories, the stories of the
previous messengers is a lesson for
those possessed of intellect. It the
Quran is not a fabricated account.
Rather, it is a confirmation of that
which came before it and an elaboration
of all things and a guidance and a mercy
for a people who believe. Once again,
the Quran confirms and
elaborates surah
35:31. And that which we have revealed
unto thee, Muhammad, from the book, the
Quran, is the truth confirming what came
before it. Verily, God is of his
servants aware seeing. The Quran
confirms what came before it. Surah
46:12.
Yet before it, before the Quran, there
was the book of Moses a guide and a
mercy. This the Quran is a book that
confirms in an Arabic tongue to warn
wrongdoers and a glad tiding for the
virtuous. The Quran confirms the Torah
in Arabic. Surah
46:30, this is about the jin reacting to
the Quran. They the jin said, "Oh our
people, truly we have heard a book, the
Quran, sent down after Moses, confirming
that which came before it, guiding to
the truth and to a straight road." The
jin say that the Quran confirms what
came before it. Surah
61:6. And remember when Jesus, son of
Mary, said, "Oh children of Israel,
truly I am the messenger of God unto
you, confirming that which came before
me in the Torah." And bearing glad
tidings of a messenger to come after me,
whose name is Ahmed. And when he came
unto them with clear proofs, they said,
"This is manifest
sorcery." Jesus confirms the Torah that
came before him. Putting all of this
together and again we only read the
Quran verses that actually use the word
confirm, we see that the Quran confirms
what the people of the book already had.
That Muhammad confirmed what the people
of the book already had. That Jesus
confirmed the Torah that came before
him. And that even the jin declared that
the Quran confirms the previous
scriptures.
How many verses did we just read
claiming that the Quran and Muhammad and
Jesus confirmed the previous
scriptures?
18. How many verses are there in the
Quran which claim that the Quran or
Muhammad or Jesus disisconfirmed the
previous
scriptures?
Zero. We read 18 verses confirming the
previous scriptures. There are zero
verses disisconfirming the previous
scriptures. Now ask your Muslim friend
what Allah says about the previous
scriptures. Your Muslim friend will tell
you with a straight face that the Quran
says the previous scriptures were
corrupted. Ask him what Allah means when
he repeatedly says he's confirming the
previous scriptures.
Oh, he only means he's confirming the
originals before they were
corrupted. Then why does he repeatedly
say he's confirming what was with
them? Why can't Allah say what he means?
If he's trying to say, "Your scriptures
have been corrupted," why can't he just
say that? Were the words not available?
Our Muslim friends expect us to believe
that when Allah says he confirms our
scriptures, he really means he
disisconfirms our
scriptures. So they want us to believe
that Allah says the opposite of what he
actually
means. Of course, if our Muslim friends
are right, then Allah is the absolute
worst communicator ever. He can't say
what he means. If we're right, Allah is
the best of Bible confirmers. If our
Muslim friends are right, Allah is the
worst of
communicators. Take your pick. If he
means what he says, he's the best of
Bible confirmers. If he means the
opposite of what he says, he's the worst
of
communicators. Isn't it strange that
critics of Islam have more respect for
the Quran than Muslims do?
We don't even believe in the Quran, but
we have more respect for the Quran than
Muslims
do. We let Allah speak for
himself. His followers twist and distort
his words beyond recognition.
To all my Muslim friends out there, let
me just
say with followers like you constantly
attacking and undermining and distorting
what Allah
says, who needs Islamophobes?
[Music]